OK, one sign that you and your high school nerd friends are pulling a lot of pranks, you give yourselves a name. And it's an acronym.
好的，有一个迹象表明你和你的书呆子高中朋友们经常恶作剧，那就是给自己起个名字，而且是一个缩写。
We were called the SCUM club. SCUM was an acronym for the Society for the Corruption and Undoing of Morals.
我们当时叫SCUM俱乐部。SCUM是“道德败坏与毁灭协会”（Society for the Corruption and Undoing of Morals）的缩写。
Another sign your prank-life is rather rich? You have a nemesis, and not only does he have the perfect job to be your nemesis-- assistant principal-- he has the perfect name, in this case--
另一个迹象表明你的恶作剧生活相当丰富？你有一个死对头，而且他不仅有着作为你死对头的完美职业——副校长——他还有个完美的名字，在这种情况下——
Merle Power.
梅尔·鲍尔（Merle Power）。
Mr. Power.
鲍尔先生。
He reminded me a lot of that principal from Ferris Bueller's Day Off . I don't know if you know that character. But it was the same kind of thing, I'm going to get you. I'm going to get you, Mr. Stein. One of these days, I'm going to get you.
他让我想起《春天不是读书天》里的那位校长。我不知道你是否了解那个角色。但就是那种感觉，我会抓住你的。我会抓住你的，斯坦先生。总有一天，我会抓住你的。
Would he literally say to you--
他会真的那样对你说吗——
Oh yeah. Yeah. There was a cast of usual suspects. And we would get called into the office.
哦，是的。确实如此。有一群常见的嫌疑人。我们会被叫进办公室。
Mr. Power's office?
鲍尔先生的办公室？
Mr. Power's office. And he would say, this happened over the weekend. And we'd go, yeah, wasn't it great? And he'd say, well, what did you have to do with it? And I'd say, well, nothing. I was at home studying my mathematics.
鲍尔先生的办公室。他会说，这事儿是周末发生的。我们会说，是啊，不是很棒吗？然后他说，好吧，那这事儿和你们有什么关系？我会说，好吧，没什么关系。我当时在家里学数学呢。
As the head of the SCUM club, Adam Stein says Mr. Power never had any evidence. And nobody ever squealed.
作为SCUM俱乐部的负责人，亚当·斯坦说鲍尔先生从没有过证据，而且从来没人告密。
But he set himself up to be tortured. A perfect example is, the prank was to stack lunch benches. And they stacked them 18 benches high in the middle of the center quad. He gets on the intercom the next morning and says, this is a bad prank. You know, blah, blah, blah, had you stacked it two more, we would have had to get a crane to come in and it would have cost blah, blah, blah. So guess what's happened the next day? We come into school and it's stacked 20 benches high. So they have to bring a crane in. And this is the sort of thing that happened all the time. He would set us up for the next step.
但他自己非要往枪口上撞。一个完美的例子是，当时有个恶作剧是堆叠午餐长凳。他们在中心广场中央堆了18张长凳高。第二天早上，他通过对讲机说，这是一个糟糕的恶作剧。你知道，巴拉巴拉什么的，如果你再多堆两张，我们就得叫起重机来，那会花费多少多少钱。所以你猜第二天发生了什么？我们来到学校时，发现它堆了20张长凳高。所以他们不得不叫来起重机。这种事儿一直在发生。他总是为我们下一步的恶作剧做铺垫。
So one next step leads to another, and that leads to another. And finally, it is the last month of senior year. There's time for one last caper. The SCUM club gathered a wheelbarrow, concrete, shovels, pick axes, maybe 15 people in all. And then, in the dead of night-- 1:00 AM-- they go to school, spread out to their pre-assigned spots, lookouts on the perimeter of the school grounds, and they got to work planting a toilet in the middle of the school grounds, right in the middle of the yard, cementing it in place and then writing on the seat, the seat of power-- for, you know, their nemesis.
所以这一步接着下一步，最后，到了高三的最后一个月。是时候进行最后一次“壮举”了。SCUM俱乐部集合了一辆独轮车、混凝土、铁锹、镐头，总共大概15个人。然后，在深夜——凌晨1点——他们去了学校，分散到预定的位置，在校园外围放哨，然后他们开始工作，在校园中间，就在操场的正中央种了一个马桶，把它用水泥固定住，然后在座圈上写上——权力之座——你知道，是为了他们的死对头。
And everything's going great--
一切都很顺利——
When we hear this, "Stop, freeze, police." We took off running in all directions. And almost within a minute, a police helicopter was over us with the lights on. And the beams were following us and the helicopter was yelling, "Stop, this is the L.A. Police. Stop."
当我们听到这个声音，“站住，不许动，警察。”我们四散奔逃。几乎不到一分钟，一架警用直升机就在我们上方，灯光照射着我们。光束跟着我们，直升机里喊着：“站住，这是洛杉矶警察。站住。”
Everybody scatters. From afar, they watch the helicopter land. They watch the police disembark. They watch the police examine the toilet. And then the police go. The next day, they deduce that the helicopter just happened to be on another call in the neighborhood. This is L.A., there was a suspect at large. None of Adam's friends were caught. In other words, best possible scenario. They got scared. They got chased. They got adventure. Nothing bad happened.
大家都跑散了。从远处，他们看着直升机降落。他们看着警察下机。他们看着警察检查那个马桶。然后警察就走了。第二天，他们推断那架直升机当时正好在附近处理另一个案子。这是洛杉矶，当时有一个嫌疑人在逃。亚当的朋友们一个都没被抓到。换句话说，这是最好的结局。他们感到害怕了。他们被追赶了。他们有了冒险的经历。什么坏事都没发生。
And the next day, of course, was the greatest day of their lives-- hundreds of kids milling around this toilet. And early in the morning, Adam is called into Mr. Power's office.
第二天，当然，成了他们一生中最棒的日子——几百个孩子围着这个马桶转。一大早，亚当就被叫进了鲍尔先生的办公室。
And I was in there and he said, I know you did this. The usual thing. I know you had something to do with this. It's two weeks before graduation. You're not going to graduate. And of course, like every single time, he had no proof. And he basically said, but I will prove this before you graduate.
我进去后，他说，我知道是你干的。老一套。我知道这事儿跟你脱不了干系。离毕业还有两周。你没法毕业了。当然，像每一次一样，他没有证据。他基本上说，但我会在你毕业前证明这一点。
When we got to graduation, which was a couple weeks later-- and it was southern California, sitting out on the lawn of our football field, 800 kids in my graduating class. So I go up, cross the stage, shake the principal's hand, get the diploma folder. And I go back to my seat and, sitting with my friends, open up to see what's inside and there are two sheets of toilet paper slid into the little plastic holder for the certificate.
当我们到了毕业典礼那天，那是几周后——在南加州，坐在足球场的草坪上，我的毕业班有800个孩子。我走上去，穿过舞台，和校长握手，拿到了毕业证书夹。我回到座位上，和朋友们坐在一起，打开看看里面有什么，结果有两张卫生纸塞进了那个放证书的小塑料夹里。
It's like he was winking at you.
就像他在对你眨眼一样。
Yeah, exactly. That's exactly right. It was like a wink. And it completely, completely changed who he was for me at that moment.
是啊，完全正确。就是那样。就像一个暗示。那一刻，他给我的形象完全、彻底地改变了。
Like suddenly you liked him?
就像突然之间你喜欢他了？
I don't know if I'd go that far.
我不知道是否能说得那么远。
Suddenly he seemed like a person.
突然间他看起来像个人了。
Yeah, he seemed like a person.
是啊，他看起来像个人了。
Did it feel like you were in a cat and mouse game with him for that year?
那一年，你感觉自己像是在和他玩猫捉老鼠的游戏吗？
Absolutely. You needed a nemesis. Had he been kind of a gentle, understanding sort of guy, it would have taken the wind out of our sails, I think. It's fun to do those sort of things. It's fun to do the cat and mouse. It's fun to tease that cat and see if he can get you, while staying within reach of the hole so you can escape into it.
绝对是。你需要一个死对头。如果他是一个温和、善解人意的人，我想那会让我们泄气。做那些事儿很有趣。玩猫捉老鼠的游戏很有趣。戏弄那只猫，看他能不能抓住你，同时保持在洞口附近以便能逃进去，这很有趣。
Well, today on our radio program, Cat and Mouse, stories of people caught in a perpetual chase, doomed to it, or sometimes-- like with Adam and his high school friends-- the chase just makes their lives more interesting. From WBEZ Chicago, it is This American Life , distributed by Public Radio International. I'm Ira Glass.
好了，今天我们的广播节目，“猫与老鼠”，讲述的是那些陷入永无止境的追逐中的人们的故事，注定如此，或者有时——就像亚当和他那些高中朋友一样——这种追逐只会让他们的生活更有趣。来自芝加哥WBEZ电台，这是《美国生活》，由国际公共广播电台发行。我是艾拉·格拉斯。
Act One of our show today, El Gato Y El Ratoncito. A guy embeds with an armed, quasi-vigilante group for a cat and mouse game on the Mexican border. Act Two, Hello Kitty. David Sedaris explains how it really goes between mouse and cat when both are locked up in prison together. Act Three, Lookings for Loveseats in All the Wrong Places, what happens when a cat is confronted with hundreds, actually thousands of possible mice and can't choose one. Act Four, Spray My Name, Spray My Name, the story of cops, graffiti writers and the graffiti writer that we believe possibly evaded the police longer than any other. Stay with us.
我们今天节目的第一幕，《猫与老鼠》（El Gato Y El Ratoncito）。一个人潜入一个武装的准治安维持组织，在墨西哥边境进行一场猫捉老鼠的游戏。第二幕，《凯蒂猫》。大卫·塞达里斯解释了当猫和老鼠都被关在监狱里时，它们之间到底是怎么相处的。第三幕，《在所有错误的地方寻找双人沙发》，当一只猫面对成百上千，实际上是几千只可能的“老鼠”却无法选择其一时会发生什么。第四幕，《喷涂我的名字》，关于警察、涂鸦者，以及我们认为可能比任何其他人都逃避了警察更久的涂鸦者的故事。请继续收听。
Act One. El Gato y el Ratoncito. Well, at this point, most of us have heard of these guys who call themselves the Minutemen. They're a volunteer militia. They station themselves at the US-Mexican border and they try to intercept illegal migrants. The founder of the California Minutemen put out a call for, quote, "All those who do not want their family murdered by Al Qaeda, illegal migrants, colonizing illegal aliens, illegal alien felons, alien barbarians, ninja-dressed drug smugglers."
第一幕。《猫与老鼠》。好吧，此时此刻，我们大多数人都听说过这些人，他们称自己为“民兵组织”（Minutemen）。他们是一支志愿者民兵队伍。他们驻扎在美墨边境，试图拦截非法移民。加州民兵组织的创始人发出呼吁，引用如下：“所有那些不想让自己的家人被基地组织、非法移民、殖民性质的非法外籍人员、非法外籍重罪犯、外星野蛮人、忍者装扮的毒品走私犯谋杀的人。”
Well, this guy who's not a professional radio reporter or anything-- in fact, in his real life he works for a pest control company-- decided to buy himself a tape recorder and just hang out with the California Minutemen for a few days on their missions to the border. The guy's name is James Spring. And what he found was completely surprising.
好吧，这个家伙不是什么专业的广播记者之类的——事实上，在现实生活中，他在一家害虫防治公司工作——他决定给自己买了一台录音机，并和加州民兵组织一起在边境执行了几天任务。这个人的名字叫詹姆斯·斯普林。而他发现的情况完全出人意料。
He found a cat and mouse game at the border that happens night after night after night, but not between the minutemen and the illegal immigrants. No, no. The minutemen have another nemesis, protesters, groups like Angels of the Desert and Border Angels, who drop food and water for the migrants trying to help them. Hundreds of people die trying to cross the border each year, from heat, from cold, some starve. And in fact, in this nightly cat and mouse game, the Minutemen really see themselves as the mice. Here's James' story.
他发现边境上每天晚上都在上演一场猫捉老鼠的游戏，但不是在民兵组织和非法移民之间。不，不。民兵组织还有另一个死对头，抗议者，像“沙漠天使”和“边境天使”这样的组织，他们为移民留下食物和水，试图帮助他们。每年有数百人死在试图越过边境的途中，因为炎热、寒冷，有些人饿死了。事实上，在这场每晚进行的猫捉老鼠游戏中，民兵组织实际上把自己看作是“老鼠”。下面是詹姆斯的故事。
My gear? A RadioShack walkie talkie that a minuteman named Larry handed me before we left the VFW. My companions? Almost all in their 50s or 60s, dressed in cammies or khaki. They have Top Gun styled call signs: Big Bob, Little Dog, Big Bird.
我的装备？一个无线电对讲机，是一个叫拉里的民兵在我们离开退伍军人协会（VFW）前交给我的。我的同伴们？几乎都在50到60岁之间，穿着迷彩服或卡其布衣服。他们有像《壮志凌云》那样的代号：大鲍勃、小狗、大鸟。
Big Bob.
大鲍勃。
You got Big Bob.
收到，大鲍勃。
I drive my own truck in the middle of a convoy of a dozen SUVs and one Toyota Corolla. As we pass a shack, somebody identifies it as a drug house. Somebody else calls it a signal house, an observatory that alerts smugglers when the coast is clear. Every vehicle on the road is suspect, too. A Chevy with sagging leaf springs surely belongs to a drug trafficker. So does the empty flatbed that reeks of dung.
我开着自己的卡车，在一支由十几辆SUV和一辆丰田卡罗拉组成的车队中间。当我们经过一个棚屋时，有人认出那是毒品窝点。另一个人称之为信号房，是一个观察点，当环境安全时会通知走私者。路上的每一辆车也都值得怀疑。一辆后叶片弹簧下垂的雪佛兰肯定属于毒贩。那辆散发着粪便味的空平板卡车也是。
It's probably got about 50 kilos in it.
那车里估计有50公斤（毒品）。
No doubt.
毫无疑问。
Tonight, our objective is to spot illegal immigrants and drug traffickers and to radio Big Bob, who will be at the top of a hill where he can get reception with his cell phone to call the Border Patrol. The convoy's main concern is that we're going to be followed by the goons, the protesters. The goons, in fact, are the number one topic of the radio chatter. The goons are not do-gooders, they say, not humanitarians. They're in league with the bad guys, on the take from the drug lords and coyotes. And then, as if summoned by fears, the goons appear.
今晚，我们的目标是发现非法移民和毒贩，并用无线电通知大鲍勃，他会在一个小山顶上，那里可以用手机接收信号，以便致电边境巡逻队。车队最担心的是我们会遭到“暴徒”，也就是抗议者的跟踪。事实上，暴徒是无线电聊天中的头号话题。他们说，暴徒不是行善者，也不是人道主义者。他们与坏人勾结，收受毒枭和蛇头的贿赂。然后，仿佛是被恐惧召唤出来一样，暴徒出现了。
A red Suzuki Sidekick with a white cross on the door and a ratty sign that says, Rescate-- Rescue-- passes us going in the other direction and flips a quick U-turn. We're being tailed.
一辆车门上印着白色十字架、挂着破烂牌子写着“Rescate”（救援）的红色铃木Sidekick在相反方向经过我们，并迅速掉头。我们被跟踪了。
I see them right there.
我看见他们就在那儿。
[UNINTELLIGIBLE PHRASE].
[听不清的短语]。
They made us as soon as we drove by. They know where we are now.
我们一经过，他们就认出我们了。他们现在知道我们在哪儿了。
Vehicle, drop your tacks.
车辆，扔掉你们的钉子（路障）。
Going down.
正在行动。
Wow. That seemed a little harsh, telling the rear vehicle to drop their tacks so that the search and rescue vehicle which spun around to follow us is now apparently going to run over tacks and have a flat tire. That can't be legal.
哇。这似乎有点过分了，告诉后方车辆扔下钉子，这样那辆掉头跟踪我们的搜救车现在显然要压到钉子并爆胎了。这肯定不合法吧。
The Sidekick keeps coming. The command about dropping the tacks-- it turns out-- was only a ruse in the hopes that the enemy was listening in on our frequency. It's only when the Suzuki gets stopped by a random US Border Patrol checkpoint that we're able to lose 'em. We leave the main road and race down a bumpy dirt track that cuts south toward Mexico. 10 minutes later, we arrive at a wide desert valley with a two-foot-high rail fence marking the border.
那辆Sidekick一直在靠近。关于扔钉子的命令——结果证明——只是一个计谋，希望敌人正在监听我们的频率。直到铃木被一个随机的美国边境巡逻检查站拦下，我们才甩掉他们。我们离开主路，沿着一条崎岖的土路向南向墨西哥方向飞驰。10分钟后，我们到达了一个宽阔的沙漠山谷，那里有一道两英尺高的铁轨围栏标志着边界。
OK, Roger. We're out of here. Let's go, guys.
好的，收到。我们撤了。走吧，伙计们。
Each vehicle is directed by radio to park 100 yards apart, creating a half-mile line of SUV sentry posts. I park beside Larry Morgan, the guy who loaned me the walkie talkie, not just because he loaned me the walkie talkie, and not just because I want to find out where I can get a T-shirt like his that says, "Undocumented Border Patrol Agent." I park next to Larry because he wears a big, floppy hat and he's the spitting image of my grandfather.
每辆车通过无线电被指挥停在相距100码的地方，形成一条半英里长的SUV哨岗线。我停在拉里·摩根旁边，就是那个借我无线电对讲机的人，不只是因为他借我无线电，也不只是因为我想知道在哪儿能买到像他那样的T恤，上面写着“无证边境巡逻特工”。我停在拉里旁边是因为他戴着一顶大大的软檐帽，简直就是我祖父的翻版。
Larry tells me that he's a retired longshoremen from Los Angeles, an ex-marine, just like my grandfather was. I ask him what the deal is out here. How do we do this thing? Larry explains that different minutemen have different styles. Some guys flood their posts with light. But not him. Larry prefers stealth.
拉里告诉我，他是来自洛杉矶的退休码头工人，前海军陆战队员，就像我祖父一样。我问他在这里到底是干什么的。我们怎么做这件事？拉里解释说，不同的民兵有不同的风格。有些人会用灯光照亮他们的岗位。但他不会。拉里喜欢隐蔽。
I go completely black. I go dark. And I just go quiet. I don't talk. Sometimes I turn my radio off. That way you can hear anything within-- your voice travels about a half a mile, maybe a mile, out here. People can hear us talking, OK? And at night, this would be a dead giveaway.
我完全隐形。我熄灭灯光。然后我保持安静。我不说话。有时我关掉无线电。这样你可以在……你的声音在这里可以传出半英里到一英里远。人们能听到我们说话，明白吗？在晚上，这会立刻暴露目标。
[UNINTELLIGIBLE] [? Bird, ?] Rescate Angels are back on the road behind us. They've found us.
[听不清] [？鸟，？] 救援天使又回到了我们身后的路上。他们找到我们了。
Damn.
该死。
We see a car approach from about a mile away with its horn honking. It's the Suzuki sidekick. Larry is walking in tight circles with his hands on his head.
我们看到一辆车从大约一英里外驶来，按着喇叭。是那辆铃木Sidekick。拉里双手抱头，在原地绕着小圈走。
So what are they going to do? Are they just going to go up and down-- I thought this was a [UNINTELLIGIBLE]--
所以他们打算做什么？他们只是要来回——我还以为这是一个[听不清]——
They're going to get on the radio and call all their goons. And they'll probably--
他们会通过无线电呼叫他们所有的暴徒。他们可能会——
They're coming up on the east end. They just found the whole line, guys. This is down at my end.
他们正从东头上来。他们刚刚发现了整条防线，伙计们。就在我这边。
Probably get four or five car loads up.
可能会来四五车人。
I don't think they have anybody to speak of.
我不认为他们有什么人。
If they've got a cell phone, they've got friends.
如果他们有手机，他们就有朋友。
Roger.
收到。
It just makes it harder for our mission. Jesus, what a bunch of numbskulls, knuckleheads. If they can't see that we're out here trying to help the Border Patrol-- which is a government agency-- why would they want to interfere?
这只会让我们的任务更困难。天哪，真是群笨蛋，傻瓜。如果他们看不出我们是在这里协助边境巡逻队——那是一个政府机构——他们为什么要干涉呢？
They're yelling warnings across the border.
他们在边境那边大喊警告。
Yup. So any chance that we had of being stealth just went out the window. You can see how they'll just get on their bullhorns and yell and make noise all night, so everybody here won't even attempt to cross and we might as well just go home.
是啊。所以我们本来可能保持隐蔽的机会现在全泡汤了。你可以看到他们会如何用扩音器整晚大喊大叫，制造噪音，这样这里的人甚至根本不会尝试越境，我们干脆回家算了。
The Sidekick makes its way down the line. When it reaches our post, Larry flags it to stop. He introduces himself very pleasantly. And the driver smiles and tells Larry that his name is Rafael. He explains, in fractured English, that he is a volunteer with Border Search and Rescue. Larry crouches down so that he's eye to eye with Rafael, and tells him that they both believe in helping people. I don't want to see anybody get hurt either, Larry says.
那辆Sidekick沿着防线开过来。当它到达我们的岗位时，拉里打手势让它停下。他非常友好地做了自我介绍。司机笑了笑，告诉拉里他的名字叫拉斐尔。他用蹩脚的英语解释说，他是边境搜救队的志愿者。拉里蹲下来，与拉斐尔平视，告诉他他们都相信帮助他人。拉里说，我也不想看到任何人受到伤害。
And then he tells Rafael to follow his heart. You just do what you have to do. And Rafael says, I believe we are both on the same side, because you love this country and I love this country. The one difference is, I've got two countries. I watch Larry nod again, interesting way to look at it. Larry pats the hood of the Sidekick and says, nice to talk to you. Rafael continues down the line. After this exchange I'm thinking, the cold war is over. The wall has come down. But instead, Larry offers this analysis.
然后他告诉拉斐尔追随自己的内心。你只要做你必须做的事。拉斐尔说，我相信我们是在同一阵线，因为你热爱这个国家，我也热爱这个国家。唯一的区别是，我有两个国家。我看着拉里再次点头，这是一种有趣的看待方式。拉里拍了拍Sidekick的车盖说，很高兴和你交谈。拉斐尔继续沿着防线行驶。这次交流后，我想，冷战结束了。墙倒塌了。但相反，拉里提出了这样的分析。
You talk to this fellow and he appeared to be reasonable, rational. It turns out that he's a suspected drug dealer and human smuggler. That's what he does and he doesn't like us here. That's the reason he's down here with his goons and they're trying to run us out of here. Amazing. And here he comes. I almost shook his hand.
你和这个家伙交谈，他看起来很通情达理，很理性。结果发现他是个涉嫌贩毒和偷运人口的罪犯。这就是他做的事，他不希望我们在这里。这就是他带着暴徒出现在这里，试图把我们赶走的原因。太神奇了。他居然来了。我刚才差点和他握手。
I ask Larry how he knows the protesters are working for drug dealers. He says the Minutemen's founder, Jim Chase, says so. And Big Bob said exactly the same thing. That's two sources, he says. Without the headlights of the Sidekick, it's really dark now. Larry settles into a lawn chair for the night.
我问拉里他是怎么知道抗议者是为毒贩工作的。他说民兵组织的创始人吉姆·蔡斯是这么说的。大鲍勃也说了完全一样的话。他说，那就有两个来源了。没有了Sidekick的车灯，现在真的很黑。拉里坐进躺椅准备过夜。
See, there's the Big Dipper. Isn't that the bottom of the Big Dipper? And then you follow that over to the North Star.
看，那是北斗七星。那不是北斗七星的底部吗？然后你沿着那个找北极星。
You know, I don't think that's the Big Dipper. I think that's our problem.
你知道，我觉得那不是北斗七星。我觉得那是我们的问题所在。
That's our problem. Well, OK, Magellan.
那是我们的问题。好吧，麦哲伦。
I think that's the one they call Cassiopeia.
我觉得那是他们所说的仙后座。
I walk back to my truck for a pair of binoculars, not that they'll do any good. There's no moon. And the entire desert is now as black and flat as a tar pit. When I get back to Larry's truck, he's pretty much abandoned the idea of stealth. I hear perhaps the strangest sound I could have ever imagined at this moment.
我走回我的卡车去拿双筒望远镜，尽管它们也没什么用。没有月亮。整个沙漠现在黑得像沥青坑一样平坦。当我回到拉里的卡车旁时，他基本上已经放弃了隐蔽的想法。我听到了此时此刻我能想象到的最奇怪的声音。
What do you think of that? Isn't that pretty? You probably never heard of them. Luis Miguel. Romantico Musico.
你觉得那个怎么样？不漂亮吗？你可能从来没听说过他们。路易斯·米格尔。浪漫音乐。
You have Mexican romantic music in your truck?
你的卡车里有墨西哥浪漫音乐？
I have six CD's that I have-- oh, I have another one, too. I can't think of his name. You'd love this stuff. It's really neat. I fell in love with this little Mexican girl about five years ago. And she introduced me to the culture. And it got me interested in it. I'd never dated a cute, little 100-pound Mexican girl. She was like a Hollywood movie star. I met her walking her dog in the park across from my home, back just before 2000. And we started seeing each other. And I was 57 and she was 28. And it was fun. I really enjoyed it.
我有六张CD——哦，我还有另一张。我想不出他的名字。你会喜欢这些东西的。真的很棒。大约五年前，我爱上了一个墨西哥小姑娘。她向我介绍了这种文化。这让我对它产生了兴趣。我以前从没和可爱的、体重100磅的墨西哥小姑娘约会过。她就像好莱坞电影明星一样。2000年刚开始前，我在我家对面的公园里遇到她遛狗。我们开始交往。我57岁，她28岁。那很有趣。我真的很享受。
Was she a Mexican from Mexico, Mexican?
她是来自墨西哥的墨西哥人吗？
She was a Mexico Mexican, illegal, no green card.
她是地地道道的墨西哥人，非法入境，没有绿卡。
Do any of your pals out here on the line know? Do they know this story?
你们在这里的伙伴知道吗？他们知道这个故事吗？
Yeah, I've shown them pictures of Christina. She's a really cutie. Anyway, I haven't met anyone quite like her. And now, I don't know what I'm doing here today. She broke my heart and dumped on me. So this is my way of getting even. Just joking.
是的，我给他们看过克里斯蒂娜的照片。她真的很可爱。总之，我没见过像她这样的人。现在，我不知道我今天在这里干什么。她伤了我的心，把我甩了。所以这是我报复的方式。开玩笑的。
Truthfully, his heart doesn't seem to be in this game. Here he is, an hour before midnight and a couple hundred miles from home and he's barely paying attention. When the Sidekick rattles by again slowly, Larry misses it. He asks if I've seen the Border Angels even as they're passing us, not three car lengths away. He sees lights that don't exist and misinterprets the ones that do. I wind up pointing things out to Larry.
说实话，他的心思似乎不在这个游戏上。离午夜还有一小时，离家几百英里，他几乎没在注意。当那辆Sidekick再次缓慢地隆隆驶过时，拉里错过了它。他问我是否看到了边境天使，尽管他们离我们不到三辆车的距离。他看到了不存在的光，误解了真实存在的光。我最后不得不指点拉里。
I just saw, up on the hill there-- see that bright light?
我刚才在山上看到——看到那束亮光了吗？
Oh yeah. Yeah, you know what? Look at that. Yeah, he was signaling, wasn't he? You'd be surprised how many people might be out here looking down at us. There, he's signaling again. I wouldn't know how to guess, but I'll bet there might be 20 people out there looking at us right now. In April, we stopped groups of 16, 14. I caught eight myself one morning, a family.
哦，是的。是啊，你知道吗？看那个。是的，他在发信号，不是吗？你会惊讶地发现外面有多少人可能在盯着我们看。瞧，他又在发信号了。我不知道怎么猜，但我敢打赌外面可能有20个人正在看我们。在四月，我们拦截了16人、14人的小组。有一天早上我亲自抓了8个，一个家庭。
This was last spring when he was volunteering with the Arizona Minutemen. Larry helped a Border Patrol agent catch a Mexican family.
那是去年春天他在亚利桑那民兵组织做志愿者的时候。拉里协助边境巡逻人员抓获了一个墨西哥家庭。
They sat down on the side of the road behind the truck while he did the paperwork. They'd bring out a clipboard-- the border patrolman-- gather information from these people. Little children, a couple of them were six or seven years old, girls. And they were frightened. They were afraid of either me or the border patrolman or both of us. But I went to my truck and brought out a case of water, small bottles of water, and shared it with them. And after a few minutes, the girls started to relax. The little ones were giggling.
当边境巡逻人员处理文书工作时，他们坐在卡车后面的路边。边境巡逻人员拿出写字板，收集这些人的信息。小孩子，有几个才六七岁，女孩。她们很害怕。她们害怕我，或者害怕边境巡逻人员，或者害怕我们俩。但我走到我的卡车前，拿出一箱水，小瓶装水，和她们分享。几分钟后，女孩子们开始放松了。小一点的孩子在咯咯笑。
And he was working his way down the group. And then finally, he handed a clipboard to this one little girl and she looked at me for some reason. And I just motioned an x in the air, because she didn't know how to sign her name. And she just thought that was the funniest thing. And then her mother laughed and her father giggled. And it became a light moment there. But I'll never forget that.
他正逐个登记。最后，他把写字板递给其中一个小女孩，她不知为何看着我。我只是在空中画了个叉，因为她不知道怎么签名。她觉得那太有趣了。然后她的母亲笑了，她的父亲也笑了。那一刻很温馨。但我永远不会忘记那个瞬间。
Anyway, they loaded them in the back-- in the cage part-- of the Border Patrol vehicle. And I just turned and left. I never saw them again. And I assume that they were taken back to the border and released. And maybe they came back the next day. Who knows?
总之，他们把她们装上车——关进笼子里——那是边境巡逻车的后部。我就转身离开了。我再也没见过她们。我假设她们被送回了边境并被释放了。也许她们第二天又回来了。谁知道呢？
Was there any-- when they were taken off-- they're loaded into a cage and you're watching a couple kids. I mean, that must have grabbed your heart a little bit.
当她们被带走时——她们被装进笼子，而你看着几个孩子。我的意思是，那一定触动了你的心弦。
Of course it did. I was responsible to a large extent for that, and it was sad. I was touched by it. I thought, what am I doing this for? Because it just was sad to see these people. It did dawn on me that, if I'm going to do this, I have to be a little stronger.
当然触动了。我在很大程度上对此负有责任，这很悲伤。我被它感动了。我想，我为什么要这么做？因为看到这些人真的很悲伤。我确实意识到，如果我要做这件事，我必须变得更坚强一点。
When Larry talks about why he's doing this, he gives the standard pitch that all these guys give. Illegal immigration has ruined the public schools, hospitals have closed because they were forced to provide free emergency care to Mexicans, then there are all the Mexican drugs that have destroyed America's children. He says he just felt like he could make a difference. "You'd be surprised," he says, "When you find something you really believe in. We just can't let any more of these people into our country."
当拉里谈到他为什么要这么做时，他给出的标准说辞和所有这些家伙一样。非法移民摧毁了公立学校，医院因为被迫为墨西哥人提供免费紧急护理而倒闭，还有那些摧毁了美国孩子们的墨西哥毒品。他说他只是觉得他能有所作为。“你会感到惊讶的，”他说，“当你找到你真正信仰的东西时。我们不能再让这些人进入我们的国家了。”
It's like going to the dog pound, or the pound. And you go in and you look at the little puppies and you look at the little kittens, and you just want to load your car and take them all home. Well, I don't go to the pound because I don't want to put myself through that. And in a way, it's the same thing here. These people, they're wonderful people, they're hardworking, but we just can't absorb them anymore. I think we've reached the point now where there's just a limit to what we can allow.
就像去动物收容所。你走进去，看着小狗和小猫，你只想装满你的车，把它们都带回家。好吧，我不去收容所，因为我不想让自己经历那种心碎。在某种程度上，这里的情况也是一样的。这些人，他们是很好的人，他们很勤劳，但我们实在无法再接纳他们了。我认为我们现在已经到了一个临界点，有些东西是我们所能允许的极限。
Suddenly, we see a stream of headlights descend into the valley behind us. The rest of the goons have arrived. It's five compact cars. A dozen or more people pile out. And one of them shouts into a bullhorn in Spanish, "Poor people of Mexico, please do not attempt to cross here tonight. There are armed men waiting for you." One guy makes fun of the Minutemen by humming the theme to Mission Impossible into a bullhorn as they pass.
突然，我们看到一串车灯降落到我们身后的山谷中。剩下的暴徒到了。是五辆小型汽车。十几个人下来了。其中一个人对着扩音器用西班牙语喊道：“可怜的墨西哥人民，请今晚不要尝试从这里越境。有武装人员在等着你们。”一个人通过扩音器模仿《碟中谍》的主题曲来嘲笑民兵组织，他们经过时，那个人一边跑一边吹奏。
[MAN HUMMING]
[男人哼唱]
The protesters park their cars in kind of an arc and the battle begins. We're in the middle of the High Desert and ideological enemies are facing off over one of the most contentious issues in the country, in two countries. And the weapons they use are about the same as you'd find in a disco, loud music, big lights.
抗议者把他们的车停成一个弧形，战斗开始了。我们处于高地沙漠的中心，思想上的敌人正在就这个国家乃至两个国家中最具争议的问题之一进行对峙。他们使用的武器和你在迪斯科舞厅里能找到的差不多：大音量音乐，大灯。
The protesters blast Mexico's national anthem and then a mix of enthusiastic Latin music. The goons, it turns out, look like college kids, boys and girls, and they're dancing and laughing in a triangle of light created by their head lamps. A couple of the protesters wave high-powered flashlights. When I reach Big Bob's truck, I find him ducking behind the cab for cover. Somebody hisses at me to get down. Big Bob is getting steamed. The scene escalates into a battle of flashlights, a kind of flash off. When one hits you in the eyes, it's blinding.
抗议者播放墨西哥国歌，然后是一首充满激情的拉丁音乐混合曲。事实证明，这些暴徒看起来像大学生，有男有女，他们在头灯形成的光三角中跳舞、欢笑。几个抗议者挥舞着高功率手电筒。当我到达大鲍勃的卡车时，发现他正躲在驾驶室后面掩护。有人嘶嘶地叫我趴下。大鲍勃火冒三丈。场景升级为一场手电筒之战，一种闪光大战。当光束照进你的眼睛时，简直让人目眩。
Should we refrain or not from hitting them with the light first, or wait till they do it?
我们是应该克制还是先用灯光反击他们，还是等他们先动手？
We're going to refrain until they hit us and then we're going to knock the hell of out them with it.
我们要克制，直到他们用灯照我们，然后我们要狠狠地用光反击回去。
The protesters flash us and Big Bob slams them with his zillion candlepower flashlight. But the protesters hold their ground. Most of them just mug it up for the spotlight, pumping their fists in the air. Some are doubled over with laughter. They turn up their music. We turn up our music.
抗议者向我们闪光，大鲍勃用他那亮度极高的手电筒狠狠地照回去。但抗议者坚守阵地。他们大多数人只是对着聚光灯做鬼脸，在空中挥拳。有些人笑得直不起腰。他们调大音乐。我们调大音乐。
[MUSIC PLAYING]
[音乐播放]
Our patriotic assault has no effect, which leads another of the minutemen to the conclusion that we have only one choice. Our version of shock and awe.
我们的爱国攻击毫无效果，这导致另一位民兵得出结论，我们只有一个选择。我们版本的“震慑行动”。
I could play the minuteman theme song.
我可以放民兵组织的主题曲。
How loud?
多大声？
Huh?
啊？
How loud?
多大声？
Real loud.
非常大声。
OK, turn it on. Crank it on.
好的，放吧。调到最大。
He cranks the minuteman theme to full volume on the stereo of his Toyota Corolla.
他把丰田卡罗拉音响里的民兵组织主题曲调到最大音量。
[MUSIC- "THE MINUTEMEN" BY GIANLUCA ZANNA]
[音乐 - 吉安卢卡·赞纳的“民兵组织”]
The words go, "We're the minutemen. We're going to stand for our country. We'll fight 'til the end." It's pathetic. The protesters have to turn down their own music in order to hear our fight song. Then they get on their bullhorns and pretend to be rednecks drawling, "Yeehaw," and "Giddy up." I'm just embarrassed for us. But next to me, a minuteman clutching a rifle is seeing the scene very differently. He's crouched against the wheel well of the truck and looks ready to radio for air support. I try to remember his name.
歌词是：“我们是民兵。我们要为我们的国家站出来。我们将战斗到底。”这很可悲。抗议者不得不调低他们自己的音乐才能听到我们的战斗之歌。然后他们拿起扩音器，假装成乡巴佬，拖着嗓子喊：“呀呼！”和“驾！”。我只是为我们感到尴尬。但在我身边，一个紧握步枪的民兵对眼前的景象有完全不同的看法。他蹲在卡车轮拱旁边，看起来准备呼叫空中支援。我试图记住他的名字。
You go by Big Dog, is that correct?
你的代号是大狗，对吧？
Little Dog.
小狗。
Big Dog's on his way down from Phoenix with more [BLEEP.] The party's just getting ready to start.
大狗正从凤凰城赶下来，带着更多的[哔——]。派对才刚刚开始。
Little Dog's real name is Robert Crooks. He's a retired commercial fishermen from Santa Barbara. The reason he's expecting sniper fire any minute, he tells me, is that L.A.'s 18th Street gang has put a bounty on their heads, because minutemen patrols have virtually stopped the flow of drugs, shutting down the gang's business.
小狗的真名叫罗伯特·克鲁克斯。他是来自圣巴巴拉的退休商业渔民。他告诉我他随时可能遭到狙击手袭击的原因是，洛杉矶的第18街帮派悬赏了他们的人头，因为民兵组织的巡逻实际上阻断了毒品流动，关闭了帮派的生意。
The bounty on our badges is $25,000 cash. And they don't even have to present the badge or the carcass because the media will cover it. They'll get their reward. And one sniper shot, that's $25,000. That's a brand-new Harley for one of these guys. You know what I'm saying? Scary, huh? In America. Man.
我们的徽章悬赏金额是2.5万美元现金。他们甚至不需要出示徽章或尸体，因为媒体会报道的。他们会得到奖金。一枪狙击，就是2.5万美元。对于其中一些人来说，那是一辆全新的哈雷摩托车。你知道我在说什么吗？很吓人，不是吗？在美国。伙计。
Reportedly, no one's ever been hurt during these rallies on the border. The only news story of protester violence was a single incident in which one protester allegedly kicked the shin of a minuteman. No charges were filed. The two sides square off for more than an hour. Then a car load of protesters makes its way down the minuteman line to deliver a message, which is interrupted every few seconds by minutemen air horns.
据报道，在边境的这些集会上从未有人受伤。唯一一则关于抗议者暴力的报道是一起孤立事件，一名抗议者涉嫌踢了一个民兵的胫骨。没有人被起诉。双方对峙了一个多小时。然后一车抗议者沿着民兵防线行驶，试图传递信息，但每隔几秒钟就会被民兵的空气喇叭声打断。
Buenas noches, senores y senoras. Gracias para the show. We'll be back again tomorrow night. It would be better if you just left, then we wouldn't have to do this every single night.
晚上好，先生们女士们。谢谢这场表演。我们明晚还会回来的。如果你们直接离开会更好，那样我们就不用每晚都这么做了。
[AIR HORN]
[空气喇叭]
You are not stopping immigration. You are not stopping drugs.
你们并没有阻止移民。你们并没有阻止毒品。
[AIR HORN]
[空气喇叭]
You are furthering this. You are furthering everything you are against. Please go home and rethink all your--
你们在助长这一切。你们在助长所有你们反对的事物。请回家重新思考你们所有的——
[AIR HORN]
[空气喇叭]
Have a nice day and this is for you.
祝你们有美好的一天，这是给你们的。
[SIREN]
[警报声]
Please go home and rethink all your values, the protesters tell us. And then they all line up their cars and leave. I wonder if this isn't exactly what the Minutemen had hoped for, a good five hours until sun up to bust some Mexicans or drug smugglers. But a few minutes later, Jim Chase crackles through on the radio and says that we're to pick up stakes, too. We're needed in a town called Jacumba.
“请回家重新思考你们所有的价值观，”抗议者告诉我们。然后他们排好车队离开了。我想这难道不正是民兵组织所希望的吗，留出五小时直到日出，去抓些墨西哥人或毒贩。但几分钟后，吉姆·蔡斯在无线电中噼里啪啦地说，我们也得撤了。我们在一个叫哈昆巴的小镇有需要。
Listening to the walkie talkie on the way down, I gather that Jacumba is considered a hostile village, and that intelligence indicates that something big is going down tonight, involving a drug smuggling cartel based in the town. By now, it's after 2:00 in the morning, and I don't know how much longer I can stay awake. When we get to Jacumba, each vehicle stops at a different street corner along the main drag, which seems to be the only paved road in town. Larry and I park by the sign that says, "Welcome to Jacumba, Population 654."
在前往那里的路上听着对讲机，我了解到哈昆巴被认为是一个敌对村庄，情报显示今晚有大事发生，涉及该镇的一个毒品走私卡特尔。此时已经是凌晨2点多了，我不知道我还能保持清醒多久。当我们到达哈昆巴时，每辆车沿着主干道停在不同的街角，那似乎是镇上唯一铺设过的道路。拉里和我停在写着“欢迎来到哈昆巴，人口654人”的标志旁。
We're supposed to write down the license plate numbers of all cars that pull onto the main road. Big Bob will call them into the Border Patrol. Larry and I stand on the corner and watch a lot of nothing. I think about how most of these guys are Vietnam vets. I think of a friend of mine who was a corpsman, how hard it was for him to return to normal life after the war. What experience has ever been as intense for them? Besides this.
我们被要求记下所有驶入主路的车辆的车牌号。大鲍勃会将号码报告给边境巡逻队。拉里和我站在街角，什么也没发生。我想起这些人大多是越战老兵。我想起我的一个朋友，他曾是一名医务兵，对他来说，战后回归正常生活有多难。除了这个，还有什么经历对他们来说如此强烈？
This is like Tikrit, Tikrit in Iraq. We could be taking incoming at any moment. I haven't seen a roadside bomb yet, but that's not to say they don't have that set up. This is a drug town. What you see is very dangerous. I'm not sure what to expect next.
这就像伊拉克的提克里特。我们随时可能遭到袭击。我还没见过路边炸弹，但这并不意味着他们没设置。这是一个毒品小镇。你所看到的是非常危险的。我不确定下一步会发生什么。
Now all we need is a car to pass.
现在我们只需要一辆车经过。
All we need is for some drug dealer dumb enough to drive out onto this highway and try to do a drug deal in front of some of my eager friends.
我们只需要某个毒贩笨到开上这条高速公路，并试图在我那些急切的朋友面前做毒品交易。
Eventually, the sheriff shows up. He tells Larry that it's great that we're here and asks if we wouldn't mind doing him a little favor. Some kid's been stealing bicycles in Jacumba, taking them right off porches. The sheriff asks if we could keep an eye out, and hands Larry a card with a phone number.
最终，治安官出现了。他告诉拉里，我们在这里真是太好了，并问我们是否愿意帮他个小忙。有个孩子一直在哈昆巴偷自行车，直接从门廊上偷走。治安官问我们能否留意一下，并递给拉里一张写有电话号码的卡片。
Soon, the border has been forgotten. The drug dealers are forgotten. Larry radios Big Bob, and within 30 seconds, all the minutemen have abandoned their posts and converged at our corner to offer the cop their support. Big Bob and another minuteman devise a plan to set out a decoy bicycle to entice the thief. They're on the case. They're watching. They're waiting. To protect us from the bad guys, they're drawing a line in the sand.
很快，边境被遗忘了。毒贩被遗忘了。拉里用无线电呼叫大鲍勃，30秒内，所有的民兵都放弃了岗位，聚集在我们这个街角为警察提供支持。大鲍勃和另一个民兵制定了一个放置诱饵自行车来引诱小偷的计划。他们正在处理此案。他们正在观察。他们正在等待。为了保护我们不受坏人的伤害，他们正在画出一条界线。
James Spring lives in San Diego and is looking for a publisher for his first book, a true life adventure story in the jungles of Panama and Colombia, in which among other things-- and I know how this is going to sound-- he's captured by Indians.
詹姆斯·斯普林住在圣地亚哥，正在为他的第一本书寻找出版商，那是一个关于他在巴拿马和哥伦比亚丛林中亲身经历的冒险故事，其中除其他事情外——我知道这听起来会怎样——他还被印第安人俘虏了。
[MUSIC- "WAKE UP, AMERICA" BY GIANLUCA ZANNA]
[音乐 - 吉安卢卡·赞纳的“觉醒吧，美国”]
Act Two, Hello Kitty. Well, as we've already seen today, sometimes it is hard to predict who's going to chase whom when it comes to cat and mice. David Sedaris has this story.
第二幕，《凯蒂猫》。好吧，正如我们今天所看到的，当谈到猫和老鼠时，有时很难预测谁会去追赶谁。大卫·塞达里斯带来了这个故事。
It was the stupidest thing the cat had ever heard of, an A.A. program in prison, like you could find anything decent in here anyway. But if it would get his sentence reduced, well, all right. He'd sign up, dance the 12 step, do whatever it took to cut out early. Once he was free, he'd break into the nearest liquor store and start making up for lost time. But between now and then, he'd sit with the sad sacks and get by with a little after-shave.
这是那只猫听过的最愚蠢的事情，监狱里的戒酒互助会项目，就像你在这里能找到什么体面的东西一样。但如果这能减轻他的刑期，好吧，那也行。他会报名，完成那12个步骤，不惜一切代价提前出去。一旦他自由了，他就会闯进最近的酒铺，开始弥补失去的时间。但在此期间，他会和那些可怜虫坐在一起，用一点须后水凑合着过。
The only thing he wouldn't do was speak at one of the meetings. As a rule, they were pretty boring. Yammer, yammer, yammer. But every now and then, someone would tell a decent story, this mink, for example, who'd swapped his own pelt for a bottle of Kahlua. The cat didn't know you could live without a pelt, but it was possible. Not pretty, that was for damn sure, but it could be done. And this mink was living proof. It helped that he had a sense of humor about it and told the story with a little pizazz, complete with sound effects and different voices. When he came to the bit about his wife mistaking him for a beef tongue, the cat laughed so hard he fell out of his chair.
唯一一件他不会做的事就是在会议上发言。按规定，会议相当无聊。喋喋不休，喋喋不休。但偶尔，有人会讲一个不错的故事，比如这只貂，他为了买一瓶卡鲁瓦酒把自己的皮毛都给卖了。猫不知道没有皮毛怎么活，但那是可能的。不体面，那是肯定的，但可以做到。而这只貂就是活生生的证明。他对这件事有幽默感，并且讲得有声有色，配上音效和不同的声音，这很有帮助。当他讲到他妻子把他误当成牛舌的片段时，猫笑得从椅子上摔了下来。
"Thank you," the mink said at the end of his little speech, "You've been a great audience." After the meeting, the alcoholics congregated for treats washed down with burnt coffee. The cat was just going back for a second cup when he overheard a mouse talking in a low voice to the bull frog who served as the prison chaplain.
“谢谢，”貂在演讲结束时说，“你们真是很棒的听众。”会议结束后，酗酒者们聚集在一起享用点心，就着烧焦的咖啡。猫正要去倒第二杯咖啡时，他无意中听到一只老鼠正低声和担任监狱牧师的牛蛙说话。
"He might be amusing, but I don't give that mink a snowball's chance in hell. In here all right, but out in the real world he's a ticking time bomb." The cat didn't know what this mouse was in for, but he was willing to bet it was something boring, fiddling with his taxes maybe, or telling some lie about some junk nobody cared about in the first place. He wouldn't know a good time if it came up and slapped him between the ears. But here he was, ragging on this hairless mink.
“他可能很有趣，但我对那只貂根本不抱希望。在这里没事，但在真实世界里，他就是个定时炸弹。”猫不知道这只老鼠是因为什么进来的，但他敢打赌那肯定是很无聊的事情，也许是偷税漏税，或者是对没人关心的破事撒谎。如果快乐撞到他的耳朵之间，他可能都认不出来。但他却在这里嘲笑这只没毛的貂。
"Refuses to take his recovery seriously. A classic example of a dry drunk."
“拒绝认真对待他的康复。一个典型的干渴酒徒的例子。”
Give the guy a break, the cat thought. The poor bastard is permanently naked. His wife left him, his chop shop was confiscated. So who the hell cares if he starts drinking again? It beats sitting around and listening to the likes of you for the rest of his miserable life. The cat didn't say any of this stuff, but he thought it. And it must have shown on his face.
“放过那个家伙吧，”猫心想。那个可怜的混蛋永远赤身裸体。他老婆离他而去，他的改装车间被没收了。所以他会不会再次酗酒又有什么关系呢？这总比坐在那里听你们这些人的废话过完余生要好。猫没把这些话都说出来，但他想到了。这一定表现在他的脸上了。
"Do you have a problem?" the mouse asked. And the cat said, "Yeah, as a matter of fact, I do." Sensing trouble, the chaplain moved between them and held out his webbed hands.
“你有什么问题吗？”老鼠问。猫说：“是啊，事实上，确实有。”意识到麻烦要来了，牧师移动到他们中间，摊开他带蹼的手掌。
"All right, gentlemen" he said, "Let's just take this down a notch."
“好了，先生们，”他说，“我们稍微冷静一点。”
"I got a problem with certain rodents," the cat continued, "The kind who think that unless you're as pompous as they are, you're going to wind up on the trash heap."
“我对某些啮齿动物有意见，”猫继续说，“那种认为除非你和他们一样自以为是，否则你注定会沦落到垃圾堆里的人。”
"Yeah?" The mouse said, "Well, I got a problem with cats who try to take someone else's inventory before they've taken their own." He was a spunky little thing. You had to give him that. Here he was, no bigger than a hair ball, yet he was more than willing to mix it up, and with a cat no less. "Don't think I'm going to forget this," he said as the chaplain pulled him back.
“是吗？”老鼠说，“好吧，我对那些在检查别人的库存之前还没先检查自己的猫有意见。”他是个有志气的小家伙。你不得不承认。他虽然大不过一个毛球，却非常愿意大打出手，而且还是跟一只猫。老鼠说，“别以为我会忘了这件事。”当牧师把他拉回时。
And the cat said, "Oh, I'm so scared."
猫说：“哦，我好怕啊。”
When dinner time came, the cat joined the mink for burgers and fries in the prison cafeteria. The mouse was on the opposite side of the room, sitting between a rabbit and a box turtle at the vegetarian table. And every few seconds, he'd look up from his plate and glare in the cat's direction.
到了晚餐时间，猫和貂一起在监狱食堂吃汉堡和薯条。老鼠在房间的另一边，坐在兔子和箱龟之间的素食餐桌旁。每隔几秒，他就会抬头看自己的盘子，然后怒视猫的方向。
"I don't know what's going on between you two," the mink said. "But you'd better find some friendly way to straighten it out. I'm telling you brother, you do not want that mouse as an enemy."
“我不知道你们俩之间发生了什么，”貂说，“但你最好找个友好的方式解决它。我告诉你兄弟，你可不想让那只老鼠当敌人。”
"What's he going to do?" the cat said, "Steal the cheese off my hamburger?"
“他能干什么？”猫说，“偷走我汉堡上的奶酪？”
"I don't know what he's going to do, but I know what he did do," the mink said. And he leaned his raw, seeping head across the table. "They say it was arson, chewed through some wires and set a police building on fire. Four German Shepherds killed on the spot, and two more so burnt their own mothers wouldn't recognize them. Now I don't know what all you think, but in my book, brother, that's cold."
“我不知道他会干什么，但我知道他做过什么，”貂说。他把那颗生肉般的头伸过桌面。“据说那是纵火，咬断了电线，放火烧了一座警察大楼。四只德国牧羊犬当场死亡，还有两只烧得连它们亲妈都认不出来了。现在我不知道你是怎么想的，但在我看来，兄弟，那太冷酷了。”
The cat dragged a fry through a puddle of ketchup. "Dogs?" you say. The mink nodded.
猫把一根薯条拖过一滩番茄酱。“狗？”你说。貂点点头。
"One of the burnt ones was two weeks from retirement, had a party lined up and everything."
“其中一只被烧焦的狗再过两周就要退休了，聚会都准备好了。”
"You're breaking my heart," the cat said.
“你真是伤透了我的心，”猫说。
The next A.A. meeting was par for the course, not a decent story to be had. Someone said he was dying for a drink and then someone else said the same thing. When that got repetitive, a member told the group why he wanted to drink.
下一次互助会会议和往常一样，没什么像样的故事。有人说他渴望喝酒，然后另一个人也说了同样的话。当那变得重复时，一名成员告诉小组他为什么要喝酒。
"Anyone else like to share?" the chaplain asked. "Any new voices we haven't heard from?" And the cat closed his eyes. He usually drifted off to sleep and came to during the serenity prayer. But today he stayed awake, waiting for the mouse to pipe up and say something stupid like "easy does it" or "fake it 'til you make it," aphorisms he couldn't go 10 minutes without repeating.
“还有人想分享吗？”牧师问，“有什么我们还没听过的新声音吗？”猫闭上眼睛。他通常会昏昏欲睡，在宁静祈祷时醒来。但今天他保持清醒，等着老鼠开口，说些像“慢慢来”或“假装直到成功”之类的蠢话，这些格言他每10分钟不重复一次就不行。
"Boys," he'd say, "When things get tough, I just have to remind myself to let go and let God." Then everyone would act as if they hadn't heard this 5,000 times already, as if it wasn't printed on flea collars, for Christ's sake.
“伙计们，”他会说，“当事情变得艰难时，我只需提醒自己顺其自然，交给上帝。”然后每个人都会表现得好像他们还没听过这5000次一样，好像上帝啊，这些话不是印在跳蚤项圈上的一样。
Today though, the mouse skipped the slogans and talked about a recent encounter that had tested his resolve. "I won't name names. But this was between myself and the sort of individual I call a pustule, the kind who likes to creep around and listen to conversations that are none of his business. That's how he gets his kicks, see.
不过今天，老鼠跳过了那些口号，谈到了最近一次考验他决心的遭遇。“我不会点名。但这发生在我自己和那种我称之为脓包的个体之间，那种喜欢四处打探、偷听不关他事的对话的人。那就是他获得快感的方式，明白吗？”
The cat said, "Why I oughtta--" And the chaplain pointed to a sign reading, no cross talk. Of all the rules, this was the lousiest, because it meant you couldn't respond directly to someone, even if he was obviously trashing you.
猫说：“我真该……”牧师指着一块写着“禁止交叉谈话”的牌子。在所有的规则里，这是最烂的一条，因为它意味着你不能直接回应别人，即使他明显是在贬低你。
"Now, I didn't know this individual from Adam," the mouse continued. "I'd seen him around, sure. But aside from being ugly, there was no reason to notice him. He was obviously no smarter than this chair I'm sitting on. But that didn't keep him from running his mouth. In fact, it was just the opposite. This pustule pushed every button I have. And just as I was about to rearrange his face, I remembered my fourth step and let it slide." There was a general murmur of congratulation and the mouse acknowledged it. "I can't say I'll be so forgiving the next time. But I guess I'll just cross that bridge when I come to it."
“现在，我以前从来不知道这个个体，”老鼠继续说。“我见过他在周围晃悠，当然。但除了丑陋之外，没有理由注意他。他显然没比我现在坐的这把椅子聪明。但这并不能阻止他口出狂言。事实上，恰恰相反。这个脓包触动了我所有的按钮。就在我正要给他点颜色看看时，我记起了我的第四步，没去理会他。”一阵赞许的低语声响起，老鼠表示接受。“我不敢说下次我会这么宽容。但我猜我到时候会想办法解决的。”
Then a goat raised his hand and recalled getting drunk at his nephew's bar mitzvah. The animals shook their head in sympathy. And the cat joined in, biding his time until a couple more had spoken. Then he could call the mouse a few names of his own.
然后一只山羊举起手，回忆起在他侄子的成年礼上喝醉了。动物们同情地摇了摇头。猫也加入了进来，等待着再有几个人发言后。然后他就可以给老鼠起几个他自己的绰号了。
Next, a guinea pig said some crap about insecurity. A leech wondered if the Big Book came in an audio version. Then just as he had finished, the cat stuck his paw into the air saying, "Hey everybody, I got a little story to tell."
接下来，一只豚鼠说了些关于不安全感的屁话。一只水蛭想知道《大书》有没有音频版本。然后就在他讲完时，猫把爪子举到空中说：“嘿大家，我有个小故事要讲。”
"That's not the way we do things here," the chaplain said. "Before you speak, you have to introduce yourself."
“我们这里不是那样办事的，”牧师说，“发言前，你必须先介绍你自己。”
"OK," the cat said. "I'm a cat and I got a little story to tell."
“好的，”猫说，“我是只猫，我有个小故事要讲。”
"You know what I'm talking about," the chaplain said. "Come on now, it's not going to kill you." The cat stared across the table at the mouse and saw the same expression he'd observed the night before in the cafeteria. Smirky, defiant, the look of someone convinced that he had already won.
“你知道我在说什么，”牧师说，“得了吧，说出来又不会死人。”猫盯着桌子对面的老鼠，看到了他前一天晚上在食堂里观察到的同样的表情。轻蔑、挑衅，那是某种确信自己已经赢了的人的表情。
"All right," the cat said, "I'm a cat and-- aw, to hell with all of you."
“好吧，”猫说，“我是只猫，然后——噢，见鬼去吧，你们所有人。”
The mouse put his little hand over his heart as if to say, oh you're killing me. And the cat pounded his paw on the tabletop. "I'm a cat, all right? I'm a cat and I'm a-- and I'm an alcoholic. You happy now?"
老鼠把他的小手放在胸口上，仿佛在说，噢，你快把我笑死了。猫用爪子拍了拍桌面。“我是只猫，好吗？我是只猫，我……我是个酒鬼。你现在高兴了吧？”
Then everyone said, "Hello, cat," and waited, their eyes politely downcast as he began the long business of recovering himself.
然后每个人都说，“你好，猫，”并等着，他们的眼睛礼貌地低垂着，当他开始他漫长的自我救赎之路时。
"So that's how I met my first sponsor," the cat would later say. This at meetings in damp church basements and low-slung community centers, years after he was released from prison. "That little SOB saved my life. Can you beat that? A murderer, an arsonist, and not a day goes by when I don't think about him."
“所以我就是这么遇到我的第一个赞助人的，”猫后来会说。这是在他出狱多年后，在潮湿的教堂地下室和低矮的社区中心举办的会议上。“那个小王八蛋救了我的命。你能相信吗？一个杀人犯、纵火犯，每天我都会想起他。”
It maybe wasn't the best story in the world. But as the mouse had told him on more than one occasion, it wasn't the worst either.
这可能不是世界上最好的故事。但正如老鼠不止一次告诉他的那样，这也不是最坏的。
David Sedaris is the author of several books, most recently Dress Your Family in Corduroy and Denim . He also has edited a collection of favorite short fiction called Children Playing Before a Statue of Hercules. Coming up, cat and mouse with a mouse that cannot even move. Why, oh why would it take 10 decades to catch? That's in a minute, from Chicago Public Radio and Public Radio International, when our program continues.
大卫·塞达里斯是几本书的作者，最近的一本是《给你的家人穿上灯芯绒和牛仔布》。他还编辑了一本名为《在赫拉克勒斯雕像前玩耍的孩子们》的短篇小说集。接下来，猫和老鼠的故事，对象是一只甚至不能动的老鼠。为什么，为什么抓它要花10个十年？一分钟后，来自芝加哥公共广播电台和国际公共广播电台，我们的节目继续。
It's This American Life , I'm Ira Glass. Each week on our program, of course, we choose some theme. We bring you a variety of different kinds of stories on that theme. Today's program, Cat and Mouse. We've arrived at Act Three of our program. Act Three.
这是《美国生活》，我是艾拉·格拉斯。每周在我们的节目中，当然，我们会选择一个主题。我们为您带来关于该主题的各种不同类型的报道。今天节目，猫与老鼠。我们来到了节目的第三幕。第三幕。
In most games of cat and mouse, you've got the chaser and you got the chased, right? And both of them are pretty much in constant motion. But here's a story where the mouse is not moving at all. In fact, the mouse is an inanimate object. And yet, somehow it cannot be caught. David Segal reports.
在大多数猫捉老鼠的游戏中，你有追逐者和被追逐者，对吧？而且它们大多都处于持续运动中。但这里有一个故事，老鼠根本不动。事实上，老鼠是一个无生命的物体。然而，不知为何它就是抓不到。大卫·西格尔报道。
I've known Eric for just about 20 years. And for nearly the entire length of our friendship, he's been hunting quarry that everyone else cornered a long time ago, something nobody really thinks of as the sort of thing you hunt.
我和埃里克认识大约20年了。在我们友谊的几乎整个过程中，他一直在搜寻猎物，而其他人很久以前就放弃了，这是没人真正认为你会去寻找的东西。
I've been looking for the right sofa for about 18 years.
我寻找合适的沙发已经大约18年了。
Yes, he said 18 years. And yes, he said sofa. All of this started after Eric left graduate school. And briefly, it looked like it would be a fairly conventional shopping experience. He spotted a sofa he liked at Pottery Barn, an off-white number with a slip cover. And he had a matching pair delivered. But once they arrived, he knew he'd made a big mistake. The lines were all wrong. The fabric wasn't right. He returned the goods within a week. And after that, the shopping experience was never conventional again. His quest moved into what I call its "Ahab/Moby Dick" phase. He began to stalk his couch.
是的，他说的是18年。是的，他说的是沙发。这一切都始于埃里克研究生毕业之后。简而言之，那看起来将是一次相当常规的购物经历。他在Pottery Barn看中了一款沙发，那是那种米白色、带沙发套的款。他买了相配的一对。但它们一送来，他就知道他犯了大错。线条完全不对。面料不对。他一周内就退货了。从那以后，购物经历就再也没有常规过。他的追求进入了我所说的“亚哈/白鲸”阶段。他开始跟踪他的沙发。
For years he'd subscribe to these high-end furniture magazines. And slowly, he started to build a clip file of advertisements and photographs. He learned the ins and outs of couch construction, the proper materials for the frame--
多年来，他一直订阅那些高端家具杂志。慢慢地，他开始建立一个广告和照片剪贴档案。他学会了沙发制作的门道，框架的正确材料——
What they call kiln-dried hardwood.
他们称之为窑干硬木。
Invisible stitching. Cushion filling.
隐形缝线。垫子填充物。
There's a firmness but a softness, which is actually not all that easy to achieve.
有一种坚固但又柔软的感觉，这实际上并不容易实现。
The fabric for the covering--
覆盖的面料——
The kind of the boucle that they do, which is the fabric that I was keen on.
他们做的那种 boucle，也就是我热衷的面料。
And of course, all important, the springs.
当然，最重要的是，弹簧。
What's called eight-way hand-tied, I think, which is, they do eight-way hand tying of the coils.
我想那叫八向手工绑扎，也就是说，他们对线圈进行八向手工绑扎。
I should say, Eric's not this way when he's buying clothes. He's not this way when he's ordering dinner. He's not this way with a lot of things. But when it's something he cares about, he's methodical and he's relentless. But with the sofa, he went further than he ever had before. By the time his search entered its 10th year-- that's more than twice as long as it took scientists at the Manhattan Project to develop the atom bomb-- Eric was honing in.
我应该说，埃里克买衣服时不是这样的。他点餐时不是这样的。他对待很多事情都不是这样的。但当这是他关心的事情时，他既有条理又锲而不舍。但对于沙发，他比以往任何时候走得都远。当他的搜索进入第10个年头时——那比曼哈顿计划的科学家研制原子弹的时间还要长两倍多——埃里克正在逼近。
He'd started shopping in these swanky boutiques, places that don't even have storefronts, places where someone has to tell you the address and then buzz you in. He had his eyes on the work of a sofa superstar named Jean-Michel Frank. And there was one piece in particular that he decided was the couch of his dreams. It was a $12,000 three-seater of Italian nutwood in a beeswax finish. Eric found the one place in the country where it was for sale.
他开始在那些时髦的精品店购物，那些店甚至没有店面，在那里必须有人告诉你地址，然后按铃把你放进去。他看中了沙发超级明星让-米歇尔·弗兰克（Jean-Michel Frank）的作品。特别是有一件他认为是梦想中的沙发。那是一款1.2万美元的三座意大利坚果木蜂蜡饰面沙发。埃里克找到了全国唯一有售的地方。
A place called Ralph Pucci.
一个叫拉尔夫·普奇（Ralph Pucci）的地方。
So you walked around this place, and did you fall in love with any of the sofas? Did you hear the church music you were looking for?
所以你逛过那个地方，你爱上过哪款沙发吗？你听到你要找的教堂音乐了吗？
Yeah, well, it's interesting. The short answer is, I didn't, which was kind of dismaying. When I saw it in person, I was actually a little underwhelmed.
是的，嗯，这很有趣。简短的回答是，我没有，这让人有点沮丧。当我亲眼见到它时，我实际上有点失望。
So you ultimately passed on all of the sofas that you came across during your 15- to 18-year search for the perfect sofa.
所以你最终放弃了你在15到18年的完美沙发搜索过程中遇到的所有沙发。
Right.
是的。
Could you describe your current sofa?
你能描述一下你现在的沙发吗？
That's just plain mean.
那简直太刻薄了。
Where did you get your current sofa?
你现在的沙发是在哪儿弄的？
So I got my current sofa for free. It was a donation from a friend that I was helping move out of his apartment. The polyester fill cushions have gotten flattened to the point where if you plop down, if you just kind of collapse into my sofa, you will actually hurt yourself.
我现在的沙发是免费得到的。那是一个我帮他搬出公寓的朋友捐赠的。涤纶填充垫已经塌陷到那种程度，如果你倒下去，如果你只是那种瘫进我的沙发里，你实际上会伤到自己。
More than a few times in these past 18 years, Eric and I have tried to figure out what this sofa thing is really about. Perhaps it won't shock you to learn that Eric is single. He's had a fair number of girlfriends. With some he's even shared the story of his never-ending couch adventure. And guess what, they don't seem very amused.
在这过去的18年里，埃里克和我曾多次试图弄清楚这个沙发问题到底是怎么回事。得知埃里克单身可能不会让你感到震惊。他交过不少女朋友。有些人甚至分享过他那永无止境的沙发奇遇。你猜怎么着，她们似乎一点都不觉得有趣。
Yeah. I mean, it kind of drives them crazy.
是的。我的意思是，这简直让她们抓狂。
To review. Just after college, he found something he liked, lived with it briefly, and then decided it wasn't good enough and sent it packing. He started pursuing exotic specimens that conformed to a narrower and more unattainable ideal. He subscribed to glossy, photo-rich magazines, which only reinforced his yearning for this unattainable ideal. And then, after years of searching, he finally came face-to-face with that ideal. He found it lacking. Do you see where I'm going here? Often, when I talk to him about his quest, I want to say, wait, are we still talking about a couch?
回顾一下。大学刚毕业，他找到了一样他喜欢的东西，住了一段时间，然后觉得它不够好，把它退货了。他开始追求符合更狭窄、更遥不可及理想的异国样本。他订阅了光鲜、照片丰富的杂志，这只会加强他对这个遥不可及的理想的渴望。然后，经过多年的搜索，他终于面对面地看到了那个理想。他发现它不够好。你知道我要说什么吗？通常，当我和他谈论他的追求时，我想说，等等，我们还在谈论沙发吗？
Do I hold out for one that really knocks me out or do I just settle for something that is-- that I can live with, but really doesn't knock me out?
我是该坚持寻找一个真正让我惊艳的，还是仅仅满足于一个——一个我能忍受但并没有真正让我惊艳的东西？
But does it not worry you that you might live a sofa-less, single life?
但你不担心你可能会过上一种没有沙发、单身的生活吗？
Yeah. I mean, absolutely. This is probably the thing that causes me more concern and dismay and questions as anything in my life. I really, really like being together. And I'm not all that crazy about being alone.
是的。我的意思是，绝对。这可能是我生活中最让我担忧、困惑和质疑的事情了。我真的、真的很喜欢在一起。而且我并不太热衷于独自一人。
One thing that's interesting about the tale of Eric's nonstop sofa safari-- which I've heard him tell more than a few times-- is that it ticks off nearly as many people as it amuses. Some are actually angry when he's done with the story. And I think I know why. Two radically different world views are clashing here, one in which life is all about seeking perfection, and the other in which you make normal compromises and settle for good instead of great. The settlers consider the perfection people to be babies and whiners. The perfection people see the settlers as strangely hostile milquetoasts who've given up, who aren't striving for greatness, who've been cowed into lowering their standards.
关于埃里克那场不停歇的沙发游猎之旅的故事，有一个有趣的地方——我已经听他讲过不止一次了——那就是它惹恼的人和逗乐的人一样多。有些人甚至在他讲完故事后感到生气。我想我知道原因。两种截然不同的世界观在这里冲突，一种是认为生活完全在于追求完美，另一种是你做出正常的妥协，满足于好而不是伟大。定居派认为完美主义者是孩子和抱怨者。完美主义者把定居派看作是奇怪的、充满敌意的、已经放弃的人，他们不追求伟大，因为他们被恐吓而降低了标准。
Personally, I know that part of me wants to tell Eric, don't yield. Do not surrender. Hold fast. Wait for that transformative moment, even if it means you're alone and drooling on a frat house futon for the rest of your life. And another part of me wants to tell him exactly what a former girlfriend once told him, and I quote, "Just buy a [BLEEP] couch."
个人而言，我知道我内心的一部分想告诉埃里克，别屈服。别投降。坚持住。等待那个改变人生的时刻，即使这意味着你余生都独自一人，趴在兄弟会宿舍的折叠床上流口水。而我的另一部分想告诉他一个前女友曾经对他说的话，引用如下：“买个该死的沙发吧。”
David Segal is a reporter for the Washington Post.
大卫·西格尔是《华盛顿邮报》的记者。
[MUSIC- "A HOUSE IS NOT A HOME" BY LUTHER VANDROSS]
[音乐 - 路德·范德鲁斯的“房子不是家”]
Act Four, Spray My Name, Spray My Name. Over the years, Brian Thomas Gallagher has followed the cat-and-mouse struggle between graffiti writers and the people who notice their work more than anybody else, the cops who are trying to bust them.
第四幕，《喷涂我的名字》。多年来，布莱恩·托马斯·加拉格尔一直关注着涂鸦创作者与那些比任何人都更关注他们作品的人——试图逮捕他们的警察——之间的猫鼠斗争。
So this is how it works. Some teenager decides he's going to start writing his name on things-- buildings, vans, windows-- and then 75 NYPD officers have full-time jobs trying to hunt him down and arrest him. They can get downright obsessive.
所以事情就是这样。某个青少年决定他要开始把自己的名字写在东西上——建筑物、货车、窗户——然后75名纽约警察全职工作试图追捕并逮捕他。他们可能会变得非常痴迷。
A lot of the officers in the unit will say, I want this guy.
该部门的许多警察会说，我想要这家伙。
This is Lt. Steve Mona. He's been with the Vandal Squad for 19 years. He knows the feeling.
这是史蒂夫·莫纳中尉。他在破坏巡逻队工作了19年。他知道那种感觉。
It becomes like a disease. You hear it when the cops come into work at night. They don't just drive down the parkway to get to work. They drive down the parkway and looking at the bridge abutments and everything. And the minute they come into work-- it's not even roll call time yet-- and you hear one cop saying to the other one, hey, did you drive down the Bronx River today? No, I didn't, why? It was clean yesterday and so-and-so and so-and-so hit it last night. They must have been out there. Damn, I was there. We passed there around 2 o'clock in the morning. I don't remember the graffiti.
它变得像一种疾病。你听到警察晚上来上班时的谈话。他们不仅仅是开过公园大道来上班。他们开过公园大道，盯着桥台和其他一切东西。他们刚一上班——甚至还没到点名时间——你就听到一个警察对另一个说，嘿，你今天开过布朗克斯河了吗？没有，没开过，怎么了？它昨天还是干净的，那个谁谁谁昨晚又喷了。他们肯定昨晚在那儿。该死，我就在那儿。我们凌晨2点左右经过那儿。我不记得有涂鸦啊。
As cat and mouse games go, this is classic. You have the writers, more nimble but less powerful, dashing out, doing their work, almost taunting. And then you have the cops, watching and waiting, and occasionally catching them. The 75 Vandal Squad cops call themselves the vandals. Some cops will get fixated on a certain writer. Officers have been known to keep snapshots of graffiti taped to their computer monitors. And for a while, Lt. Mona's screensaver was a piece by a notorious writer named Lee. They study a writer's work, learn his style and habits. They follow them to and from their houses. They know where they work. They keep thick dossiers full of photos of different tags.
作为猫捉老鼠的游戏，这是经典的。你有涂鸦者，更敏捷但权力较小，冲出来，完成他们的工作，几乎是嘲弄。然后你有警察，观察和等待，偶尔抓住他们。这75名破坏巡逻队的警察自称为“破坏者”。有些警察会对某个创作者产生执念。据了解，警察会将涂鸦的照片贴在他们的电脑显示器上。有一段时间，莫纳中尉的屏幕保护程序是一个臭名昭著的创作者“李”的作品。他们研究创作者的作品，了解他的风格和习惯。他们跟踪他们往返住所。他们知道他们在哪儿工作。他们保存着装满不同涂鸦照片的厚厚档案。
Tags are what a graffiti writer writes, their graffiti alias. To most people, they barely look like English. Vandal Squad cops are pretty much the only people in the city besides the writers who can read them. In an odd way, a Vandal Squad cop can become a writer's biggest fan. But the writers know the cops, too. Steve Mona is famous. Although they don't keep files on him.
涂鸦（Tags）是涂鸦创作者写的，他们的涂鸦别名。对大多数人来说，它们看起来几乎不像英语。破坏巡逻队的警察几乎是城里除了创作者之外唯一能读懂它们的人。以一种奇怪的方式，破坏巡逻队的警察可以成为创作者最大的粉丝。但创作者也了解警察。史蒂夫·莫纳很出名。尽管他们不保存他的档案。
They actually took my I.D. card photo, which was on the NYPD website and made a stencil out of it. And that was getting stenciled all over the place. I've had stuff written about me, about my sexual orientation and things like that. The first time it happened, I was offended by it. And then a chief who I worked for at the time said, if they're writing your name instead of their own, you're doing a good job.
他们实际上拿了我的身份证件照片，那照片就在纽约警局的网站上，做成了一个模具。然后那东西到处都被喷上了。关于我，关于我的性取向之类的事情，上面写了很多东西。第一次发生时，我被冒犯了。然后我当时的一位主管说，如果他们在写你的名字而不是他们自己的名字，那说明你工作做得好。
And that's not all. I was talking about Mona with a graffiti writer that goes by the appetizing tag of Earsnot when this came up--
不止如此。我和一个名字叫“耳垢”（Earsnot）的涂鸦创作者谈论莫纳时，发生了这件事——
I've seen his Friendster thing. I know somebody else did that. I'm sorry.
我见过他的Friendster页面。我知道是别人做的。很抱歉。
He has a Friendster page?
他有一个Friendster页面？
There was a Friendster page of this cop with a mustache that looked-- and it said Mona. Somebody was putting up stencils of that. It was obviously a character that somebody else created about him.
有一个Friendster页面是这个留着胡子的警察，看起来——上面写着莫纳。有人在到处喷这个模具。显然是一个别人关于他创作的角色。
After he told me about the Friendster page, I looked it up. It is actually a photo of Mona lifted from the Vandal Squad website. Among his listed hobbies are spray paint, markers, Rikers Island, and ruining a kid's life who just wants to have some fun.
在他告诉我Friendster页面后，我查了一下。那实际上是一张从破坏巡逻队网站上截取的莫纳照片。他列出的爱好包括喷漆、马克笔、赖克斯岛监狱，以及毁掉一个只是想找点乐子的孩子的生活。
Graffiti writers actually give specific cops nicknames, like Bongos, whose name is a play on his actual name, Bogliole. Or Iceman, who looked like the character from Top Gun . And then there were Tom and Jerry, because their names were, in fact, Tom and Jerry like the cat and the mouse.
涂鸦创作者实际上给特定的警察起了绰号，比如“邦戈”（Bongos），他的名字是他真实名字“博格里奥”（Bogliole）的谐音。或者“冰人”，看起来像《壮志凌云》里的角色。然后还有“汤姆和杰瑞”，因为他们的名字确实是汤姆和杰瑞，就像猫和老鼠一样。
First of all, let me just say, every time I've gotten chased, I've gotten away. So I have a 100% record of running and getting away.
首先，让我说，每次我被追赶，我都逃脱了。所以我有着100%的逃跑成功率。
Is there an enjoyable aspect to the fact that the cops are looking for you and after you?
对于警察在盯着你、追着你这件事，有没有什么享受的地方？
It feels good to be wanted. No matter what anybody says, no matter how-- what kind of want it is. It's dope. They want to get me. It's Bonnie and Clyde, it's Wilt Chamberlain. They just want you.
被通缉感觉不错。无论任何人说什么，无论是什么样的通缉。这很棒。他们想抓我。这是邦妮和克莱德，这是威尔特·张伯伦。他们就是想要你。
One strange thing about this game is that it's actually really hard to convict anyone for writing graffiti. The police can't just know who you are. They have to catch you in the act. And if they do, they can only charge you with that one offense, even if they know you've blanketed all of Brooklyn with that exact same tag. Once you're in court, most judges don't take graffiti very seriously. Even the biggest cases tend to end in community service or probation. Still, every major graffiti writer has been arrested multiple times.
这个游戏的一个奇怪之处在于，实际上很难因为写涂鸦给任何人定罪。警察不能只知道你是谁。他们必须当场抓住你。如果他们抓住了，他们只能以那一种罪名起诉你，即使他们知道你已经用完全相同的标记覆盖了整个布鲁克林。一旦上了法庭，大多数法官对涂鸦并不太在意。即使是最大的案件通常也以社区服务或缓刑告终。尽管如此，每个主要的涂鸦创作者都被逮捕过多次。
Not long ago, Earsnot gave the cops a little gift by giving an interview in a graffiti documentary called Infamy . It hasn't been released. And even the director doesn't know how it ended up in the Vandal Squad's hands. Here's the clip that got him in trouble.
不久前，“耳垢”通过在一部名为《声名狼藉》的涂鸦纪录片中接受采访，给警察送了一份小礼。它还没发行。甚至连导演都不知道它最终是怎么落入破坏巡逻队手中的。这是让他陷入麻烦的片段。
Do it in day time, midtown, easy. People in suits are like, mmh, I didn't see that.
白天做，市中心，容易。穿西装的人就像，嗯，我没看见。
He's walking down the street in broad daylight, tagging mailboxes, windows and doors with a fat silver marker.
他大白天走在街上，用一支粗号银色马克笔在邮箱、窗户和门上喷上他的涂鸦。
I like it, especially when I can see the cop and I'm like, catching my tag and then, uh-huh, and done. Circle. Underline. Star.
我喜欢这样，尤其是我能看见警察，然后我就像，趁机喷上我的标记，然后，嗯哼，搞定。画圈。划线。打星。
We knew who he was. He's doing his tag in the video.
我们知道他是谁。他在视频里喷他的标记。
That's Lt. Mona.
那是莫纳中尉。
We have him doing the graffiti on video.
我们有他喷涂鸦的视频。
This is the nature of me and most of the [? freedom ?] writers. You don't want anybody telling you what to do. You want to [BLEEP] break the law. You want to take that chance of getting caught and you love it. And you love [BLEEP] with them and being like, I'm going to do it again and again.
这就是我和大多数[自由]创作者的本质。你不想要任何人告诉你做什么。你想要[哔——]违法。你想要冒被抓的风险，而且你喜欢它。你喜欢[哔——]跟他们玩，就像，我要一次又一次地做。
The officers watched and then they stopped the video. OK, we got a street sign. OK, I know the neighborhood. And then just let me drive. I drive up one street then down the next street and up the one street until they found those particular locations.
警察看了视频，然后他们暂停了。“好吧，我们有了一个路标。”“好吧，我认识那个街区。”然后就让我开车。我开过一条街，又开过下一条街，然后再开过那条街，直到他们找到了那些特定的地点。
And they did.
他们找到了。
And you arrested him at work?
你在他工作时逮捕了他？
And he was arrested.
他被捕了。
The case is still open, though, and Snot's holding out. I talk to him in the same exact store that he walks into on the video, the same exact store where he was arrested. And he explained it all this way.
案件仍然公开，但“耳垢”在坚持。我在视频里他走进的那家店里和他谈话，就在他被捕的同一家店。他以这种方式解释了一切。
They saw someone who looked like me doing something in a movie and they just assumed that they were going to arrest me and everything was going to be all right.
他们看到一个长得像我在电影里做某事的人，然后他们就假设他们要逮捕我，一切都会好起来的。
I can see where you are. So I know that I'm not getting caught. You know what I'm saying?
我能看见你在哪儿。所以我知道我没被抓到。你知道我在说什么吗？
The person in the video is either Earsnot or someone wearing a meticulously well-realized Earsnot costume. Then there's a graffiti writer who managed to evade the police longer than anyone else. The guy whose tag was Revs. Revs accomplished one of the most extensive and sustained graffiti projects of all time. He didn't just bomb as many walls as he could. He didn't just write his name. He wrote his entire autobiography on New York City itself, on the walls of the subway tunnels.
视频里的人要么是“耳垢”，要么是一个穿着精心打扮的“耳垢”戏服的人。然后还有一位涂鸦创作者，他逃避警察的时间比任何人都久。那个标记是“雷夫斯”（Revs）的家伙。雷夫斯完成了有史以来最广泛、最持续的涂鸦项目之一。他不仅炸毁了他能找到的所有墙壁。他不仅写了他的名字。他在纽约市本身、在地铁隧道的墙壁上写了他的整本自传。
Down there, between the stations, he would paint a swath of wall white, say 4 feet by 10. And then on the white patch, he would write in black spray paint-- page after page-- telling his life story in the dark, in a place where no one would read it. The pages are signed, numbered and dated. There are 235 of them, one between almost any two stations in the city. I've seen a few dozen and they are quite moving and impressive. Even Lt. Mona thought they were interesting. Little poems, he called them.
在那里，车站之间，他会把一片墙刷成白色，大概4英尺乘10英尺。然后在白色的补丁上，他会用黑色喷漆写——一页接一页——在黑暗中讲述他的生活故事，在一个没人会阅读的地方。这些页面上有签名、编号和日期。总共有235页，几乎在城里任何两个车站之间都有。我看过几十页，它们相当感人且令人印象深刻。甚至连莫纳中尉也认为它们很有趣。他称之为“小诗”。
For years, it was a mystery, even to the cops, how he did it and who he was, how he got a roller, a ladder, and a bucket of paint into the tunnels at night, all while dodging trains and cops and track workers. Cops would read the pages for biographical details, like page two, where Revs gives the date of his birth and the name of the Brooklyn hospital where he was delivered, Victory Memorial in Bay Ridge. He was 8 pounds, 13 ounces. A C-section.
多年来，即使对警察来说，他怎么做到的、他是谁、他怎么在晚上把滚筒、梯子和一桶油漆带进隧道，同时躲避火车、警察和轨道工人，都是一个谜。警察会阅读这些页面以获取传记细节，比如第二页，雷夫斯给出了他的出生日期和出生地布鲁克林医院的名字，贝岭的胜利纪念医院。他重8磅13盎司。剖腹产。
This went on for years, the Vandal Squad chasing him the whole time. Finally, he was caught in the act, arrested, charged, and convicted, not only with graffiti and trespassing, but also possession of stolen property, which he was wearing. A stolen subway worker's uniform, that's how he was able to evade the police all those years. Everybody who saw him with the buckets of paint just thought he belonged down there.
这种情况持续了多年，破坏巡逻队一直在追捕他。最终，他被当场抓住，被捕、被起诉并被定罪，不仅是因为涂鸦和非法入侵，还因为持有他身上穿的赃物。一件被偷的地铁员工制服，这就是他多年来能够逃避警察的原因。每个看到他提着油漆桶的人都以为他属于那里。
The officer who caught and interrogated him, James Bogliole-- the one graffiti writers call Bongos-- has probably read more of his pages than any non-writer. He told me he'd spent so long chasing Revs, piecing him together, sort of forming him in his mind, that it came to be that he understood him a little.
那个抓住并审讯他的警官詹姆斯·博格里奥——就是那个涂鸦创作者称之为“邦戈”的人——读过的页面可能比任何非创作者都多。他告诉我，他花太长时间追捕雷夫斯，拼凑他的信息，在脑海中形成他的形象，以至于他最终对他有了一点点理解。
Revs turned out to be a 33-year-old ironworker from a working class neighborhood, not so different, really, from any of the cops pursuing him.
雷夫斯原来是一个来自工人阶级社区的33岁钢铁工人，实际上与追捕他的任何警察没什么两样。
Brian Thomas Gallagher is a senior editor at Topic magazine.
布莱恩·托马斯·加拉格尔是《话题》杂志的资深编辑。
Well, our program today was produced by Alex Blumberg and myself, with Diane Cook, Jane Feltes, Sarah Koenig, Amy O'Leary, and Lisa Pollak. Our senior producer's Julie Snyder, Elizabeth Meister runs our website. Production help from Sam Hallgren, Thea Chaloner, Seth Lind, Tommy Andres. Music help from Jessica Hopper.
好了，我们今天的节目由亚历克斯·布卢姆伯格和我本人制作，黛安·库克、简·费尔特斯、萨拉·凯尼格、艾米·奥利里和丽莎·波拉克参与。我们的资深制作人是朱莉·斯奈德，伊丽莎白·迈斯特负责我们的网站。萨姆·霍尔格伦、西娅·查洛纳、塞思·林德、汤米·安德烈斯提供制作帮助。杰西卡·霍珀提供音乐帮助。
[ACKNOWLEDGEMENTS]
[致谢]
[FUNDING CREDITS]
[资助名单]
This American Life is distributed by Public Radio International.
《美国生活》由国际公共广播电台发行。
[FUNDING CREDITS]
[资助名单]
Hey, everybody, I got a little story to tell.
嘿，大家，我有个小故事要讲。
Oh, WBEZ management oversight by Torey Malatia who, I guess, has something he wants to share with everybody.
哦，WBEZ的管理监督是托里·马拉蒂亚，我想，他有什么想和大家分享的。
I'm a cat, all right? I'm a cat and I'm a-- and I'm an alcoholic. You happy now?
我是只猫，好吗？我是只猫，我……我是个酒鬼。你现在高兴了吧？
Hello, Torey. Back next week with more stories of This American Life .
你好，托里。下周再见，会有更多《美国生活》的故事。
PRI, Public Radio International.
PRI，国际公共广播电台。